la forma de la señal también es muy
importante sobre todo cuando hablamos de
alcoholes aquí tenemos un alcohol
general y lo que nos importa es el
enlace entre el oxígeno y el hidrógeno
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo así que tiene una carga parcial
negativa y este hidrógeno tiene una
carga parcial positiva lo mismo ocurre
con este alcohol así que el hidrógeno
parcialmente positivo se siente atraído
al oxígeno parcialmente negativo y esa
fuerza de atracción debilita a este
enlace oxígeno hidrógeno sabemos que al
debilitar la fuerza de un enlace
disminuye la constante de fuerza y como
vimos en el vídeo anterior
si disminuye k disminuye la frecuencia o
número de onda así que la señal cambiará
en el espectro y
entonces en cualquier momento las
diferentes moléculas de alcohol formarán
enlaces con los hidrógenos y puede ser
que algunas moléculas formen pocos
enlaces con lo que cada disminuye un
poco al igual que el número de onda pero
puede ser que las moléculas formen
muchos enlaces con los hidrógenos con lo
que que disminuye aún más al igual que
el número de onda así que cuando se
forman enlaces con otros hidrógenos
tenemos una variación en los números de
onda para el enlace o h y por lo tanto
veremos una señal muy ancha en el
espectro jr
entonces si analizamos esta región en el
espectro
r del 1 examen esta región corresponde a
los enlaces con hidrógenos si dibujamos
una línea a los 3000 números de onda un
poco antes de 3000 tenemos el
estiramiento del enlace carbono hydro
donde el carbono tiene una hibridación
sp3 pero esta señal ancha corresponde a
lo h este enlace entre el hidrógeno y el
oxígeno nos da esa señal ancha que
podemos ver en el espectro y abarca
diferentes números de onda generalmente
se encuentra entre 3.500 y 2900
aquí tenemos 31 32 33 34 35 aunque puede
llegar a ocupar un poco más entonces
esta señal tan ancha corresponde al
enlace oxígeno hidrógeno y si la
encuentran en su espectro
r inmediatamente sabrán que tienen un
grupo funcional alcohol en su molécula
ahora dibujemos una línea en 1500 esta
señal en aproximadamente 1100
corresponde al enlace carbono oxígeno
que sería este enlace porque aquí
tenemos la región del enlace simple en
vídeos anteriores calculamos el número
de onda aproximado para el estiramiento
de un enlace simple carbono oxígeno
entonces así es como se ve el espectro
para un alcohol busquen la señal ancha
muy bien ahora comparemos este alcohol
con este otro alcohol que se conoce como
butil hidroxi tolueno o bht he dibujado
dos moléculas porque esta podría ser una
oportunidad para que se dé un enlace con
otro hidrógeno así que esperaríamos ver
una señal ancha para este o h que se
debilita pero en este caso tenemos mucho
impedimento estético
estos grupos tributos y eso evita que se
formen enlaces con otros hidrógenos así
que por el impedimento estético estas
moléculas no pueden acercarse lo
suficiente para que se formen los
enlaces con otros hidrógenos así que al
analizar el espectro
r para el vih t primero dibujemos
nuestra línea aproximadamente en 3000
observen que aquí no tenemos una señal
ancha aquí no tenemos esta señal ancha
pero si tenemos una señal puntiaguda se
encuentra en vamos a ver aquí es 32 33
34 35 36 está aproximadamente en 3600 y
esta señal corresponde al enlace
h así que no tenemos una señal ancha
porque no se forman enlaces con otros
hidrógenos pero tenemos una señal
puntiaguda
h entonces si tienen un enlace oxígeno
hidrógeno y no se forman enlaces con
otros hidrógenos verán una señal en
aproximadamente 3.600 pero si tienen un
estiramiento del enlace oxígeno
hidrógeno y se forman enlaces con otros
hidrógenos encontrarán una señal ancha
muy bien veamos otra ahora tenemos un
ácido carboxílicos aquí tenemos 1 h así
que se podría formar un enlace con otro
hidrógeno y si analizamos el espectro y
r cuál será esa señal
bueno ya habíamos dicho que se puede
encontrar entre 3.500 y 2900 observen
que aquí tenemos una señal aún más ancha
que antes y eso es porque el ácido
carboxílicos forma más enlaces con otros
hidrógenos les mostraré aquí tenemos una
oportunidad para formar una
la cee y aquí tenemos otra así que al
formar varios enlaces con otros
hidrógenos la señal de lo h en el ácido
carboxílicos es más ancha entonces esta
señal corresponde al estiramiento de
este enlace oxígeno hidrógeno ahora
nuevamente dibujemos una línea en 3000
justo aquí observen que esta señal
corresponde al estiramiento del enlace
carbono hidrógeno donde el carbono tiene
una hibridación sp3 generalmente el
centro de la señal ancha se encuentra
alrededor de 3000 y eso eclipsa
parcialmente a la señal que corresponde
al enlace carbono hidrógeno esto es algo
que ocurre cuando tenemos son ácidos
carboxílicos y otra forma de reconocer
que tenemos un carbón y lo es cuando
vemos esta señal tan fuerte que aparece
aproximadamente en 1700
si dibujamos una línea por aquí esta es
la región del doble enlace y aquí
podemos ver esta señal tan intensa que
se encuentra aproximadamente en 1700
corresponde al estiramiento del doble
enlace carbono oxígeno el carbón y lo
entonces si se encuentran con una señal
muy ancha para él o h
y también tiene esta señal fuerte que
corresponde al carbón y lo h y un carbón
y lo forman un ácido carboxílicos así
que es muy fácil identificar un ácido
carboxílicos con un espectro y er
anteriormente
hablamos de que la formación de enlaces
con otros hidrógenos debilita el enlace
hidrógeno oxígeno
bueno aquí ocurre algo muy parecido si
se forma un enlace con otro hidrógeno
eso debilita al carbón y lo debilita un
poco al doble enlace
y por lo tanto la señal cambiará y el
número de onda disminuye así que la
señal para este carbón y lo aparecerá en
un número de onda menor al que
esperábamos mencionaré un poco más sobre
eso en otro vídeo por ahora para la
forma de una señal recuerden que si hay
enlaces con otros hidrógenos entonces
aparecerá una señal ancha